if you're watching this video is loading
slowly and you're in the United States
there is a reason why
the United States is now ranked
thirty-year in broadband speed
and that we pay more than many other
West United Nations we've got some info
for you
so US download speeds right behind
Iceland Romania Bulgaria France Russia
the UK and many more
we also pay more an average a fifty-five
dollars a month for broadband service
while countries with faster connections
like someone they just mentioned
come in at about forty-five dollars a
month a Hong Kong which has the fastest
internet speeds in the world
they pay about 40 percent less than we
pay
about 31 bucks a month I I guess this
shouldn't surprise us because it seems
like most the bar
stop in the United States is not working
that well our infrastructure
now our broadband um is it weird that
we're not talking about
this more that this that because
everything's online the computer
it's all online should we be more
concerned about our slow ass
internet what struck me is what I'm
curious about really after reading that
article was
how many of those countries how much
government investment
but obviously look I get the government
invested a lot in the Internet to be in
with but
to keep those speeds up to date like is
it all the business is just do it
themselves
is that they're motivation or is there
get is that government work to make sure
because there is a vested interest
for business purposes for every purpose
that were government
newburgh the government use a press
release guys get subsidies from the
government
yeah I would imagine the they do and
we're leaving it up
pretty much to near as I can tell I'm
have all the information here but we're
leaving it up Comcast try to merge with
time-warner
which will have so many customers it a
lot
there's no infected for them updated and
make sure that move into the top five or
top 10
because when you have how many customers
they're about to have
120 million whatever it is a great
mergers allowed to go through
though control half the country's get
high-speed internet in the bill were
with me they're all pain fifty-five
dollars a month we literally
we can't we don't know what to do with
all this money writes a plate only
getting worse the Time Warner Comcast
thing is only gonna make this worse than
what was the one this week DirecTV and
AT&T
so that even try to make that make up
anything going on that matter so
it's only going to get worse because
they have no interest because there's so
little competition
well I think teddy roosevelt taught us
that a huge monopolies are a good thing
it they help their economy they help
beer they help the general public
everybody gets the get a piece of the
pie yeah 11
person owns everything yeah in that
about we were gassed up calling a
broadband 2014 to woman band its okay
I don't know why I we keep doing that
sorry sorry I don't know why
go yet why I so that the last merger
that they didn't approve
the federal government was way and
a was its not sprint but the what's the
other 11 to be taken over by any way
they did not let one of those murders go
by which I couldn't believe you never
surprised because one
up if they hear here's a tip: if the
merger it doesn't benefit to consumers
are not supposed to let it happen at 11
merger happen with it said
it to benefits the company but not the
consumers and that's what happened so
we're gonna get less choice right when
this merger happens
when I get less choice when I get poor
service already at higher prices
yet they're gonna let this go through
because we live in a banana republic
not technically banana but I like the
issues that term
me corrupt you're close enough what
happened to USA number one
are we number one in anything anywhere
we number one then way well you know me
we said above me said
we are number one in bankruptcies
attributed to medical care
we're number one I think any
industrialized world and infant
mortality
so we can get a lot number ones so we've
got a couple years with another one a
gun deaths
number one yet on that we had a lot of
those number one but back in the day and
those things were
where there any that really I guess at
one point we must have had the number
was certainly a growing economy as early
as someone growing economy in the world
and
you know where we're number one in war I
you know they say about the Washington
Senators before they left out
you know what Washington was first in
war first in peace
your last in the American League and a
but now we're not even would not even a
first and be
no one no one would know it would no one
would
right argue that with a straight face I
i worry about like
that did something like the Internet the
way that
the again it just feels like that the
this us maintaining
elite internet speeds and status like
that requires government intervention
somehow I'm not saying they have to pay
to but then they have to subsidize it
they have to spur
well they would have to tell Comcast
paid you have to up but we're gonna
allow this
were here here a deal by 2022
were sixth in the world make that happen
whatever did get the speed up to
whatever it needs to be yeah does the
government in a weird way have a vested
interest in our internet not being met
good
no i i buy that we cannot we want to
access the information is easily
well i think i hula hoop in benefits
what what I think should be happening
is that the municipality should be
making internet available to everyone
for free
right because they done studies and they
figured out that the places that do that
actually helps everyone's business
I with your able to access the air wifi
no matter where you are inside the city
it their business goes up productivity
goes up tax revenue goes up
so it pays for itself it's one of those
things that helps people get kids get
educated kids can get on the internet
whatever they want
at school at home on the bus no matter
what so this is it so they can have wifi
so that's what we of course that's what
we should be doing
just like patton have hulking universal
health care what you have universal
white by
an Internet access because that helps
everybody in rises or everyone because
we won't
because there's money in a select few
people in keeping it the way it is
so speakers select few people so we done
every week been on stories on net
neutrality so net neutrality got flipped
it was by an FCC appointed guy that was
an Obama campaign bundler
who also I worked in the telecom lobby
is at the telecom lobbyist
so between this story and net neutrality
is the Internet as we know it really on
shaky ground right now
like are we in our last are so I
Chrissy's on shaky ground right now
was we don't we don't really live in and
baca see that's what where our leaders
are responsive to
the there are people that they are
voting from the voters are only
responsible to the dollar class we say
all the time
and you know what happens when you look
at the gun control right we talk about
all ninety percent of the people want a
background check
we didn't get it what do you call that
what kinda government do we have this is
in a democracy anymore
this is government by the few for the
few one of the few
bring us home I was pretty effective
bring it home I don't think
that you know with the let's let's wrote
let's bring it
let's take a nice brought finish in make
it much narrower that's what we like to
do
what television a home I sorry but
you know the net neutrality debate is
not over that's the good news is a good
word to keep talking about are not say
that we should be dismissed
but the the FCC commissioners
seem open to at the to wear that public
debate period
to hearing about disorder period and so
I don't know I'm pointlessly
I'm always a little optimistic and I
think that's ridiculous but hit not be
there
I stay that way it not signed and sealed
yet and part of that is that we
talk about it and say that the need to
be preserved